wir alle erleben diese pandemie wir alle
erleben diese massiven einschränkungen
und trotzdem sage ich jetzt in diesem
moment nicht dass ich mich sofort impfen
lassen würde dachte gibt es ja einen
guten grund was wäre denn die
alternative wäre ja nur die strategie
auf jeden immunität zu legen das schien
mir extrem unverantwortlich da hätte ich
große bedenken
der korona impfstoff ist endlich da und
damit hoffentlich die erlösung und der
weg raus aus dieser krise aber um diese
pandemie wirklich richtig wirkungsvoll
bekämpfen zu können müssten wir uns doch
schon alle impfen lassen oder nicht eine
gesetzliche pflicht die wollen
tatsächlich die wenigsten aber sollten
wir uns nicht alle zumindest moralisch
verpflichtet fühlen uns gegen korona
impfen zu lassen meine heutigen gäste
die sind sich dazu tatsächlich sehr
uneinig aber ich möchte sie mit 13
fragen natürlich zum kompromiss führen
und verrat noch mal der hinweis wir
möchten keine wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse in frage stellen und haben
natürlich auch kein platz für
verschwörungs gedanken
die erste frage von 13 fragen die geht
wie immer an euch was denkt ihr zum chor
ohne impfstoff würdet ihr euch impfen
lassen schreibt es mir gerne in die
kommentare
es geht jetzt erstmal darum eure
position überhaupt kennen zu lernen weil
wir wissen ja gar nicht wo steht ihr was
denkt ihr über dieses thema deswegen
habe ich jetzt drei fragen für euch und
wenn ihr meiner frage zustimmt dann geht
er einen schritt in richtung erstes
casting grünes feld und wenn nicht dann
ins gelbe fällt
ich lege los mit der zweiten frage von
13 fragen es ist eine moralische pflicht
sich schnellstmöglich gegen korona
impfen zu lassen aufgrund der
wirtschaftlichen gesundheitlichen und
sozialen folgen der korona pandemie
[Musik]
ich denke es ist eine moralische pflicht
sich sobald möglich gegen hunger impfen
zu lassen weil wir alle tagtäglich
einschränkungen erleben und wir zusammen
zur normalität zurückkehren können wenn
wir alle uns impfen lassen und da an
einem strang ziehen vertraut ihr den
zulassungskriterien für den krone im
stoff ja oder nein
ich bin unentschlossen mich gegen korona
impfen zu lassen angesichts dessen dass
ich mutter bin von drei kindern war mir
dafür zum jetzigen zeitpunkt überhaupt
keine daten vorliegen dem er ein gutes
gefühl geben würden die mich sicher
fühlen lassen würden
so eine entscheidung zu treffen ist es
richtig dass menschen ohne corona
impfungen in zukunft nachteile im
gesellschaftlichen zusammenleben in kauf
nehmen müssen
ein jeder muss für seine für die folgen
seiner entscheidung eintreten und wenn
jemand ausflug mit fug und recht sagt
ich möchte mich nicht impfen lassen dann
muss er natürlich die folgen akzeptieren
die damit einhergehen ich halte es für
nicht richtig wenn menschen aufgrund
einer nicht durchgeführten corona
impfung irgendwelche nachteile zu
befürchten haben sollten weder beim
konzertbesuch noch bei reisen noch
gegenüber ihrem arbeitgeber also eure
position sind damit klar wenn ihr gerade
zukunft und ich denke ich würde mich
jetzt auch vor gerne auf diesem feld
positionieren dann schreibt mir sehr
gerne wäre er aufs gelbe oder wird er
aufs grüne feld gegangen
ab jetzt geld noch wieder andere regeln
wenn ihr mir jetzt zustimmt dann geht er
einen schritt auf mich zu
beziehungsweise natürlich immer auf die
andere seite einen schritt zu oder wenn
ihr nicht zustimmt dann geht er einen
schritt nach hinten wenn ihr schon ganz
hinten seid dann bleibt er einfach
stehen die nächste frage die geht an
eurer seite
aktuell wollen in deutschland nur 53
prozent sich gegen korona impfen lassen
sollte es nicht eine pflicht sein um
eben die wirtschaftlichen sozialen und
gesundheitlichen folgen dieser pandemie
bekämpfen zu können
was sagt ihr
nein schon wieder warum für mich ist es
wichtig dass es in der demokratie in der
wir leben eine möglichkeit gibt da frei
entscheiden zu können auch nach wie vor
auch wenn es momentan so ist dass sich
53 prozent nur impfen würden
ich bin ganz stark dass davon aus das
ist auch ganz viel mit den informationen
zu tun hat die vielleicht so an uns
bürger noch nicht angetreten sind das
für die sicherheit bekommen konnten und
für mich ist das nicht die logische
konsequenz dann in den zwang zu gehen
stefan ach du bleibst stehen ja ich
würde sagen es liegen einfach auch gar
nicht genügend informationen vor als ich
ihr können auf grund von
pressemitteilung als ärzte nicht seriös
dazu aussagen machen
das wäre unseren patienten gegenüber
unverantwortlich und ich halte es auch
persönlich für unverantwortlich aufgrund
dieser informationslage das zu tun
abgesehen davon sind uns die studienjahr
bisher nicht veröffentlicht und wir
können im grunde darüber nicht seriös
urteilen also die fehlenden
informationen die hindern euch daran zu
sagen ja aber wir möchten ja diese
pandemie so schnell es geht los werden
und einfach los nadel rein und impfen
ok also eure position ist klar würde ich
sagen ich komme zu euch die
bundesregierung die sagt dass es keine
impfpflicht geben wird also kann jeder
selber entscheiden ob er sich impfen
lassen will oder nicht aber in der
praxis im wert schon dass es schwierig
wird also es gibt zum beispiel schon
fluggesellschaften die sagen sie würden
gerne nur geimpfte personen in zukunft
mit fliegen lassen wie gehen wir dann
mit einer indirekten impfpflicht um
führt das nicht zu ungerechtigkeiten im
alltag
[Musik]
ich denke dass wenn wir es ohne solche
einschränkungen nicht schaffen im rahmen
der impfung die pandemie einzudämmen und
das infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen
dann bin ich persönlich der meinung dass
menschen die sich aktiv dagegen
entscheiden sich impfen zu lassen
auch mit gewissen einschränkungen im
öffentlichen leben umgehen müssen
andreas stimmt dazu ich stimme zu in
kauf nehmen muss man nachteile sie
dürfen nur keine strafe sein dass
dagegen wir ich es dürfen keine
grundrechts einschränkungen erfolgen
das werde ich immer ablehnen also wenn
damit beispielsweise verbunden wäre das
dann kinder oder jugendliche oder
anderen nicht mehr zur arbeit oder nicht
mehr in die schule gehen dürfen
da würden menschen rechtliche ansprüche
verletzt das müsste ausgeschlossen
werden aber im privatrechtlichen bereich
müssen möglicherweise nachteile in kauf
genommen werden
sie werden ja auch heute schon immer in
kauf genommen denn wenn ich mich
beispielsweise nicht gegen gelbfieber
impfen lassen oder andere
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ergreifen dann kann
ich auch nicht alle in alle anderen
länder hinein reisen also das muss ich
nicht abwägen
jamila magst du nix tja ja wieso das
klingt für mich schlüssig und für mich
insofern auch in ordnung solange es
keine strafe ist solange es nicht
bedeutet dass weil ich nicht impfen
geimpft bin kategorisch nicht mehr
fliegen kann das ist noch mal was
anderes als in bestimmte länder wo es
vielleicht nochmal eine andere aber so
weit so weit kann es tatsächlich sein
dass es so weit kommt also wenn
fluggesellschaften sagen nein du bist
nicht du kannst dich mit fliegen dann
bist du ja schon auch eingeschränkt wenn
du dich nicht und das wäre für mich auch
schwierig also da er gibt es den
schmalen grat zwischen habe ich direkt
mir bitte da würde ich sagen es gibt
kein menschenrecht auf flugreisen es
gibt das recht mobil zu sein und sie ihr
zu reisen aber nicht schrankenlos und
insofern bin dass die konsequent wäre
das ist ein privatrechtlicher vertrag
die die fluggesellschaft mit dem
passagier ein geht und wenn der sagt zum
schutz meiner der an
und fluggäste möchte ich also bestimmte
schutzvorkehrungen machen finde ich das
dann legitim die frage ist ja dann finde
ich
worum geht es hier geht es hier um ein
flug oder geht darum zu reisen als
mensch also in andere an anderen ort
oder an andere länder
und wenn das damit die vorkehrung sein
soll dass ich nicht fliegen darf weil
ich nicht kämpft bin um sich in einem
anderen land anzukommen
dann bringt es mir auch nichts mit dem
auto hin zu fahren und dann geht es ja
um eine andere einschränkung es ist ja
auch wahrscheinlich dass es nicht nur
beim fliegen bleibt oder es könnte ja
zum beispiel auch seinen hier in diesem
raum finden normalerweise auch konzerte
statt das soll dann auch nicht
reinkommen kannst ich hoffe dass das so
nicht kommen würde ich finde die
vorstellung ganz schwierig das würde ja
eine große spaltung mit sich bringen da
möchte ich noch mal sozusagen ein haken
gerne weil ich mal gerne zurück fragen
möchte wie wäre das wir haben ja
durchaus erkrankung auch in der
vergangenheit immer wieder gehabt die
eine ähnliche mortalität haben ja also
ich würde sie gerne zurück fragen müssen
wir eigentlich damit rechnen dass wird
wenn wir demnächst eine starke grippe
epidemie mit einer starken hohen etwas
höheren mentalitäten 2018 hat man das
zum beispiel dass wir demnächst die
konzerthäuser dementsprechend schließen
dass wir ähnliche maßnahmen
grundsätzlich wir müssen ja die
verhältnismäßigkeit dann auch angucken
geht es hier nur um corona oder geht es
um eine ganz grundsätzliche frage im
umgang mit infektionen erkrankung ich
bin da völlig entspannt
also ich sehe diese sieht die situation
nicht auf hinzu kommen in der tat dann
würde ich dir sofort recht geben also
insofern müsste ich schon praktisch in
richtung gehen ja oder in der bitte
bitte aber da weil ich bin deshalb auch
entspannt weil die frage der
herdenimmunität oder der gruppen
immunität schon viel früher erreicht ist
und dann finde ich es völlig legitim
wenn man also 20 prozent der bevölkerung
ich würde euch greift das jetzt mal das
recht zugesteht sich nicht impfen zu
lassen
ich glaube dann wird auch unter
wirtschaftlichkeit effekten hinter
quantas oder die anderen darauf
verzichten solche verbote auszusprechen
denn die wollen ja schließlich geld
verdienen aber das entscheidende ist für
mich was sind die massiven negativen
begleiterscheinungen die schäden die
jetzt zu erkennen sind durch anlockte
entweder wir haben ein kollaps des
gesundheitssystems gehen wir das einfach
laufen lassen würden ja also
über die normale gewöhnliche strategie
der jeden und militär laufen lassen
würden schweden ist als letzte land das
umgeschwenkt ist ja oder aber wir hätten
auf dauer eine solche form von begleitet
und es sind ja nicht nur wirtschaftliche
begleiten schäden es sind massive
gesundheitliche begleit schäden
es sind massive einschränkungen für die
besonders wohl nach abend gruppen in
alteneinrichtungen und dergleichen
das ist extrem sozusagen belastend und
auch tödlich belastend für diese
menschen und da muss ich ganz offen
sagen wenn das zu verhindern gilt und
deshalb hinkt der vergleich mit dem
gewöhnlichen grippe impfungen und
dergleichen weil daraus entstehen ihm
halt nicht diese erheblichen negativen
schäden und deshalb würde ich sagen muss
man bei corona einen anderen maßstab
anlegen als beispielsweise bei vielen
anderen risiken riskanten erkrankungen
aber gerade da möchte ich kurz ein mal
reingehen weil du hattest ja auch gerade
noch gesagt dass es komplett okay es
werden zum beispiel 20 prozent sagen wir
möchten uns nicht impfen aber wenn man
sie jetzt mal daran denkt dass aktuell
aber nur 53 prozent sagen dass sie sich
impfen lassen würden
das muss ja ein grund haben also wir
alle erleben diese pandemie wir alle
erleben diese massiven einschränkungen
ich habe drei kinder das ist eine
massive sowohl finanzielle als auch
emotional seelische einschränkung für
für uns und ich bin da jetzt nur als
beispiel 40 familien wir alle erleben
dass und trotzdem sage ich jetzt in
diesem moment nicht dass ich mich sofort
impfen lassen würde dafür gibt es ja
einen guten grund
und nicht weil ich gerne leider nicht
weil ich es in okay finde was in kauf
genommen wird während so eines lockt
downs oder während einer pandemie oder
dass ich nicht durchaus wahrnehmen was
das bedeutet mich um meine oma zu sorgen
mich um meine mutter zu sorgen und
trotzdem entscheide ich mich
verantwortungsbewusst so dass ich nicht
genug informationen habe um jetzt zu
diesem zeitpunkt einer impfung für mich
oder meine kinder zuzustimmen
und das hat ja das muss ja auch im
gleichen maße dann so berücksichtigt
werden als dazu hinterfragen wieso ist
das so
oder kann es nicht beantwortet werden
vielleicht ich würde gern was sagen und
zwar denke ich dass von tag zu tag neue
informationen kommen
ja aber das ist ja alles ein prozess und
es wird ein zulassungsverfahren
durchlaufen dieses zulassungsverfahren
hat kriterien und ich persönlich bin
davon überzeugt dass wenn ein impfstoff
dieses zulassungsverfahren durchlaufen
hat und wird zugelassen dann ist er auch
wirksam und sicher und dann kann man
auch mit guten gewissen sich impfen
lassen mit diesem wirkstoff und ich
denke dass immer um davon auszugehen
dass ein impfstoff sicher ist muss es ja
mindestens zehn jahre getestet sein also
auf welcher grundlage von studien kann
man sagen dass ein impfstoff mit seinen
derartigen eingriff sicher ist wenn wir
von weiß ich nicht wie vier monaten
sprechen aber man muss ja sagen man muss
sich ja man muss sehr genau betrachten
welche sozusagen prozesse jetzt
optimiert wurden
um möglichst schnell zu einem ergebnis
zu kommen so einen impfstoff zu lassen
zu können
und viele von diesen prozessen waren
auch organisatorische prozesse das sind
sage ich mal bürokratische prozesse die
die beschleunigt wurden einfach weil ja
jetzt im moment wirklich bedarf ist ja
aber ich meine er die langzeitfolgen an
man an den menschen oder einen kindern
genau das würde ich ganz gerne ergänzen
wir wissen doch aus der medizinischen
forschung dass wir oft jahre brauchen um
spätfolgen zu sehen wir brauchen
langzeitbeobachtungen wir brauchen post
marketing beobachtungen um seriös über
einen eingriff urteilen zu können
der immerhin einer ganzen bevölkerung
vorgenommen wird insofern widerspruch
auf der einen seite völlig zustimmung
dass man viele spätfolgen erst spät auf
ihn zukam
das ist eine langfrist beobachtung und
wir können uns bei keiner impfung alle
nebenfolgen auch langfrist neben folgen
ausschließen dass können wir irgendwie
bei so guten überhaupt keine
medizinische intervention also das ist
wir haben immer ein restrisiko auf
dieses restrisiko ist da also ich meine
dass die ethische grundlage gegeben ist
dass ich sage es gibt eine hohe
bereitschaft und es gibt für mich eine
innere pflicht so interpretiere ich uns
moralische pflicht moral höflich ist
eine pflicht dass ich
nicht verpflichtet fühle etwas
beizutragen zum schutz meiner selbst
beziehungsweise auch alle anderen das
unterschreiten eine moralische pflicht
von einer rechtspflicht die ich ablehne
richtig deshalb ist es hier eine
freiwillige entscheidung muss es auch
sagen jeder kann selber für sich
entscheiden welche risiken er ein
eingeht wenn ich sage ich lasse mich
sofort impfen tue ich das im bewusstsein
dass ich mich auch einem risiko
möglicherweise negative
langzeitwirkungen alles parcours
aber das ist es möglich das ist es mir
wert sozusagen um die negativen folgen
dieses lockdown cw sehen zu bremsen denn
was wäre denn die alternative die
alternative wäre ja nur auf erden
strategie auf also die strategie auf
herdenimmunität zulegen und das schien
mir extrem unverantwortlich da hätte ich
große bedenken
ich möchte die persönliche runde
eröffnen es geht ein bisschen darum dass
wir eure persönlichen erfahrungen
motivation verstehen warum ihr gerade
auf dem feld dort steht wo er steht und
melzer ich möchte mit dir anfangen
stamina der selber auch gesagt
normalerweise dauert es viel viel länger
was sind dann die erfahrungen die du
machst warum denkst du denn das ist eine
moralische pflicht ist sich irgendwann
zu lassen
ich persönlich vertraue absolut in das
zulassungsverfahren ich vertraue darauf
dass ein impfstoff da zugelassen ist
dass der wirksam und sicher ist und dass
wir da auf jeden fall eine moralische
verpflichtung haben zu tun was wir tun
können um zusammen als gemeinschaft in
richtung normalität wieder zu schreiten
und was mir ganz besonders wichtig ist
es gibt es im kinder die oder menschen
generell die besondere vorerkrankungen
haben im mund sprechen haben die sich
nicht impfen lassen können und ich denke
dass es auch man muss sich mal
vielleicht an die lage an der mutter
rein versetzen die ein solches kind hat
er dies darauf angewiesen dass das
umfeld sich impfen das also da finde ich
habe und wir haben alle eine moralische
verpflichtung
eben diese gruppe an menschen in der
gesellschaft zu schützen also jetzt in
corona teilen aber auch generell mit
impfungen also was ist es für dich auch
vor allem solidarischer akt absolut
genau das würde ich jetzt aber auch gern
von euch wissen ist impfen für euch ein
solidarischer akt dann schreibt es mir
gerne in die kommentare
ich komme auch gerne da ist stärker in
die mitte gar keine frage und das halte
ich auch als arzt für meine ganz
entscheidende pflicht eltern zum
beispiel die eine bestimmte impfungen
die in diesem kontext gegen eine
erkrankung zum beispiel berichtet ist
wie masern oder sowas dagegen darf
darüber aufzuklären dass sie damit eine
ganz hohe verantwortung eingehen wenn
sie beispielsweise ihr kind jetzt nicht
impfen
also das ist da bin ich sozusagen völlig
völlig dabei ich habe aber angesichts
ich habe bin seit 20 jahren in dem feld
unterwegs und mache eben halt vor allen
dingen auch die erfahrung dass eltern
die kritische fragen zu bestimmten
impfungen stellen keine chance länger in
der praxis zu verweilen
das halte ich für einen unhaltbaren
zustand und zwar deshalb weil ich glaube
impfungen beruhen auf einer ganz
entscheidenden währung dass es vertrauen
und habe das vertrauen in diesen
zulassungsprozess nicht ganz so weil ich
auch weiß wie die meisten im studien
finanziert werden sie werden über 90
prozent durch die produzenten selber
finanziert der staat enthält sich hier
an der stelle ist halte ich für ein
riesiges problem weil jemand der geld
gibt mit einem riesigen wirtschaftlichen
interesse dahinter natürlich interesse
auch hat am ausgang von studien insofern
würde ich das vertrauen da etwas trüben
wollen ohne dass ich hier schlechte
stimmung machen will ich möchte da nicht
falsch verstanden werden natürlich
brauchen wir die pharmazeutische
industrie
die brauchen wir auch als partner darum
geht es mir nicht aber wir müssen
trotzdem offen darüber sprechen dürfen
wenn dieser gesellschaft und wir müssen
das auch zum thema machen und wenn wir
das nicht offenbaren thema machen wird
das vertrauen einbrechen ich finde das
geht schon eher in die richtung
verschwörungstheorien wenn man jetzt
sagt naja das irgendwie durch die
finanzierung und also das
zulassungsverfahren am ende das wird
geprüft ja das wird geprüft und zwar
nicht von dem von dem unternehmen das
den impfstoff herstellt sondern dass es
in deutschland das paul-ehrlich-institut
das sind das sind wissenschaften
wissenschaftlerin
das sind experten experten und also dass
das teile ich einfach nicht ja also da
habe ich habe ich das vertrauen und muss
ich auch sagen ich finde das ist nicht
richtig zu sagen wir müssen in den
dialog treten und das erklären sondern
ich finde
dialog da bin ich absolut dabei und ich
finde es auch nicht gut eltern
abzuweisen
die skeptisch sind die sich unsicher
sind aber was ich finde dass man muss
diese menschen davon überzeugen und das
vertrauen schaffen weil das sind eltern
und was die wollen es ihr kind zu
schützen
ja das ist das ist deren motivation da
bist du mir wahrscheinlich zustimmen
das ist das was die wollen ja und da
muss man sozusagen ganz klar sagen da
ist der wissenschaftliche konsens dass
impfungen da der weg sind stabiler du
hast das auch schon gesagt du würdest
dich aktuell nicht gegen korona impfen
lassen wie reagiert dann dein umfeld auf
deiner aktuell kritische meinung zur
corona impfung
ich höre wenn andere das kritisieren
dass ich kritisch bin dass es auch ein
ärger darüber gibt dass es jetzt nicht
für alle eine gute lösung ist und es
wäre so schön wenn es für alle eine gute
lösung wäre
und die ist es für mich nicht und dann
ist das für andere schwierig weil ich
deren meinung in dem moment nicht teile
ich habe glücklicherweise jetzt noch
nicht persönlich erlebt dass ich dafür
egoistisch oder unsolidarisch wäre
grundsätzlich ist es für mich aber so
dass für mich selbstverständlich ist
mich an alle regeln zu halten die
momentan gegeben sind die dazu bei
führen dass wir im idealfall diese
zahlen hier auch wieder so runter
kriegen und da habe ich ja auch ein
großes interesse daran ich bin nicht
dagegen und ich möchte auch auf gar
keinen fall in eine schublade gesteckt
werden in richtung verschwörungstheorie
oder da sehe ich mich überhaupt nicht
auch wenn ich kritisch in einem
getesteten impfstoff gegenüber warum ist
sie dann gerade auch diese kritische
haltung demgegenüber so wichtig meine
mutter ist dafür auf die straße gegangen
dafür dass wir kritisch sein dürfen wir
leben jetzt glücklicherweise in einer
zeit wo wir das dürfen ohne dass es uns
im idealfall zum verhängnis wird
und in so einer frage über eine
impfstoff sollte das doch wirklich drin
sein kommt er einen schritt auf sie zu
ja aber das ist doch nicht der
streitpunkt
ich finde es dass es absolut legitim und
auch erlaubt sein muss nicht nur
moralisch legitim sondern auch erlaubt
sein muss die kritik die skepsis
sozusagen vorzutragen und deshalb
vielleicht würde ich dir
ein punkt ist und ganz hundertprozentig
zustimmen mit dem absoluten vertrauen in
die zulassung aber ich bin ganz kind
dieser gesellschaft und ich weiß dass
offizielle zulassungsverfahren kritisch
begleitet werden ist nicht erst seit
gestern sondern ich bin west mensch
sozusagen ich kenne die zusagen die
button seit 60er 70er jahren sozusagen
immer eine kritische gegen wissenschaft
aufzubauen
und deshalb habe ich ein großes
vertrauen dass die zulassungsverfahren
in deutschland oder europa ausreichend
verlässlich sie ich würde in diesem
punkt sagen für mich ist es ein ausdruck
von solidarität wo sich impfen zu lassen
aber ich würde es nie sagen dass die
kritische einstellung zu einem impfen
jetzt ein ausdruck von mangelnder
solidarität ist noch nicht ganz genau
dass auch nicht sozusagen das auch so
melissa übrigens ich persönlich sehe das
ein bisschen anders ich sehe also für
meine eigene situation zumindest würde
ich sagen ich bin medizinstudentin ich
bin in kontakt mit patienten
patientinnen und ich mache alles damit
ich da niemanden anstecken unwissentlich
ja und da das treffen wir sowieso
tagtäglich vorkehrungen und krankenhaus
und infektionen zu vermeiden und für
mich ist es persönlich eine absolute
verpflichtung kommen wir mal zurück zur
solidarität um das einfach mal jetzt zu
verstehen an einer in einem praktischen
beispiel findest du das also jetzt von
jamila unsolidarisch wenn sie sagt sie
lässt sich nicht impfen
oder findest du es nur in deinem fall
und solidarisch wo du mit patientinnen
zum beispiel in kontakt ist ja ich frage
mich halt ob deine entscheidung anders
ausfallen würde wenn du jetzt zum
beispiel die mutter eines kranken kind
wärs ja also ich glaube einfach dass das
einen unterschied macht dass man sich da
vielleicht auch in verschiedene wurde es
menschen reißt auch anders wie bitte die
kontexte sind ja auch immer
unterschiedlich also arbeite ich in
deinem beruf würde ich natürlich auch
andere entscheidungen treffen ganz
grundsätzlich für mein leben noch und du
stellst das jetzt nebeneinander durch
das jetzt nebeneinander dass ich das ja
leichtfertiger machen könnte und damit
einer mutter helfen würde die in einer
situation ist wo
ist ganz lebens überlebenswichtig ist
dass die umgebung geimpft ist und ich
nicht und dafür wenn ich die information
hätte dass diese impfung dieses kind
tatsächlich schützt dann ist das nicht
ganz andere moralische frage als in
diesem moment wo jetzt diese impfung auf
den markt kommt wo gar nicht klar ist ob
ich dieses kind wirklich helfe aber
unter umständen mein kind total schade
aber sich wichtig wenn du es hast du
gesagt hast wenn diese informationen
vorliegen und du mit guten gewissen
denken impfen lassen kannst dann würdest
du es auch machen ich glaube da hast du
was verwechselt
es geht nicht darum dass ich das mit
dann mit einem guten gewissen mache es
ist dann eine andere moralische frage es
ist dann die frage ob ich bereit bin
mein kind ein risiko auszusetzen für den
schutz eines anderen kindes was nicht
die wahl hat das ist nur moralisch
andere frage
und dann kann ich mich damit anders
auseinandersetzen dann würde ich das
vielleicht immer noch nicht mit gutem
gewissen machen für mein kind
aber dann würde sich vielleicht richtig
anfühlen das zu tun ich bin auch davon
überzeugt dass wenn wir genau das machen
in der gesellschaft dass wir genug
dialog haben dass wir aufklären über die
tatsachen dass wir dann auch ohne so
eine politische impfpflicht eine
genügende impfrate erreichen können um
quasi ein gemeinschafts schutz und
aufzubauen in der gesellschaft es gibt
aktuell von euch hier allen auf dem feld
niemanden der sagt wir brauchen eine
gesetzliche impfpflicht chemie da
würdest du dann zustimmen ja quasi für
die moralischen appell weil sie genug
informationen da sind dass man sich
selbst da richtig kann ich also um das
nur ganz gut sein kann ich absolut mit
gehen ja aber einen schritt auf ihn zu
gehen übrigens ja aber dann bin ich ja
schon fast hier was verheiratet da fand
ich würde auch gerne bei dir bleiben
viele wollen sich vom staat nicht
vorschreiben lassen wie sie ihre eigene
gesundheit oder die anderer schützen
sollen und du hast es ja selber auch
schon gesagt in einer praxis nimmst du
dir gerne die zeit dafür wenn eltern zu
dir kommen und sorgen haben fragen zum
thema impfung grundsätzlich was sind
denn deine erfahrung beim thema corona
impfstoff was denn da die größten sorgen
grundsätzlich habe ich einige patienten
die einfach mit einem sehr individuellen
schicksalen
die praxis kommen da ist zum beispiel
irgendeine onkel hat einen schweren
image schaden gehabt ob das stimmt oder
nicht kann ich oft nicht beurteilen aber
am familientisch ist das so rezipiert
worden und so diskutiert worden dh die
kommt in meine praxis und sagt nie kommt
dieses kind wird nie geimpft
und wenn das kind und wenn ich das
liebevoll und wohlwollend diese sache
erstmal begleitet diese lage begleitet
dann mache ich immer wieder die
erfahrung dass die eltern dann wenn die
kinder etwas älter werden tatsächlich
darüber nachdenken die kinder dann auch
impfen zu lassen
und ich kann eigentlich sagen dass auch
die die es gibt natürlich extra echte
verweigerer auch von impfungen aber ich
kann eigentlich sagen der ganz ganz
große teil der überwiegende teil lässt
sich gegen die wirklich relevanten
erkrankungen dann auch wirklich
freiwillig impfen
und das geht eigentlich so ein bisschen
in die richtung aber es bedeutet und das
möchte ich einfach nur noch mal betonen
dass ich eben halt auch diesen raum
öffnen
ja ich muss den raum öffnen dass jemand
auch seine skepsis mal ausdruck kantone
sofort zu sagen dass er nicht recht hat
ohne und das zu entwerten was er sagt
übrigens ihr könnt euch auch gerne zu
dem was stefan gesagt hat positionieren
ihr könnt euch bewegen könnte auf ihn
zugehen stehenbleiben zurückgehen was
reinraum öffnen für dialog und offene
gespräche und sorgen annehmen und sich
sorgen widmen und da irgendwie ein gutes
gefühl vermitteln bin ich absolut dabei
also dass auf jeden fall sehr gut einen
schritt auf dich zu andreas ich mache
mir vielleicht jetzt unbeliebt in dem
ich sagen es geht um die verhinderung
des kollabierenden gesundheits ist
ebenso zu sagen ja mit schwerwiegenden
folgen auch für andere bereiche
es steht zu vermuten in den ländern des
südens werden vermutlich um ein vieles
mehr menschen sterben nicht an kurven 19
schon allein aufgrund demografischen
gründen sondern an unterbrochenen im
ketten hiv aids malaria und er gleich
nicht also das heißt dieses diese
pandemie bedroht zu sagen das system als
ganzes und darin sehe ich die
gefährlichkeit und dadurch stetig
freimütig da kann ich auch natürlich
durchaus skrupel haben auch aber da
würde ich sagen hier gehe ich das riesig
co das sozusagen erwartbare risiko eines
einer nebenfolge vielleicht sondern
alles im schadens eines größeren selbst
wenn er mich betrifft weil ich aber
insgesamt der überzeugung sind bin ja
dass das also eine vernachlässigende
größe ist auch wenn sich das für
denjenigen der dann ins geschädigt ist
nun eher zynisch anhören mag das ist
aber das ist bei fast allen punkten der
familie zunächst ja weil ich glaube dass
es genau das ist das ist eine
perspektive die man einen und je weiter
man rauskommt und je größer man im
grunde dann wirklich guckt worum es geht
nicht dick fühlt sich dann natürlich
auch eine individuelle entscheidung an
und dennoch lebe ich ja in meinem leben
und ich habe dieses und treffe
entscheidung mit bestem wissen und
gewissen indem ich informationen bekomme
und diskutiere und gespräche und sichten
bekomme die dann dazu führen dass ich
mir im idealfall eine meinung bilden
kann
die ich er vertrete ihr habt der in der
vergangenen zeit ist auch schon sehr
viel über mögliche alternativen über
lösungsansätze und so weiter gesprochen
und da möchte ich mich jetzt komplett
darauf konzentrieren für eine runde ich
habe nämlich drei mögliche
lösungsansätze für euch und ich bin
gespannt was ihr dazu sagt und ob er den
zustimmt und ob wir uns darauf einigen
können weil bestenfalls sollte natürlich
alle mit viel abstand hier im konsens
corona kroner fällt wird sagen im
konsens feld lang hälfte frage von 13
tragen wir sollten nicht jeden der sich
kritisch zum impfstoff direkt als
verschwörungsdenken oder
verschwörungsdenken abstempeln sondern
wir sollten genau hinhören und offenen
dialog fördern
stimmt ihr zu dann könnt ihr als ein
schritt auf mich zukommen
zwölfter frage von 13 fragen sind wir
uns eigentlich dass wir alle kein bock
auf die krone impfung haben aber das für
sie und alle informationen und
erkenntnisse die es zu ihr gibt brauchen
um diese pandemie zu bekämpfen
nein warum können das reicht ja nicht
aus informationen und erkenntnisse in
welchem zeitfenster zu dem zeitpunkt wo
die wo wir also jedes buch da ist und
wie alle informationen und erkenntnisse
dazu haben reicht ja nicht aus du willst
mehr zeit du wirst mich zu bekommen
dreizehnte frage von 13 fragen können
wir uns auf eine impfpflicht einigen für
bestimmte berufsgruppen also zum
beispiel ärztinnen pflege erinnern oder
auch menschen im öffentlichen dienst
sobald sie immunität des impfstoffs
gewährt ist wenn ihr mir zustimmt könnte
er quasi ins konsens feld kommen
seid ihr alle einen schritt davon
entfernt hier stimmt alles nicht sie in
dieser pauschalität nicht denn dieser
pauschalität nicht ja auch wir beide
auch nicht nur deshalb schon ja also gut
wahrscheinlich könntest du mich auch
noch überzeugen mit den einschränkungen
wenn man das ganze noch mal ein bisschen
genauer beleuchtet tendenziell sehe ich
erst mal kein problem aber ich denke
immer dass man sowas differenziert
betrachten muss auf jeden fall des wegen
offener dialog das haben wir jetzt
gerade gemacht vielen dank für euch alle
dass er teil dieser diskussion war
ich habe die diskussion offen liebt
ich habe wieder einmal erlebt dass es
sinn macht da an die themen heranzugehen
und wirklich drum zu ringen auch
gemeinsam und nicht so sehr übereinander
zu reden sondern miteinander und in dem
sinne glaube ich war das heute eine
gelungene diskussion
ich glaube dass es ganz wichtig ist dass
wir kritisch bleiben dürfen und ich
glaube dass es aber auch ganz wichtig
ist dass wir offen bleiben uns halt auch
wirklich beide seiten anzugucken und
diese freiheit kritisch bleiben zu
dürfen werde ich weiterhin vertreten und
hoffe dass es trotz mit der
differenzierung passieren wird dass das
nicht bedeutet dass man
verschwörungstheoretiker rinn ist oder
impfgegner als ich glaubte oder
gegnerinnen ich glaube da gibt es noch
ganz ganz viele abstufungen und da tun
wir uns allen einen großen gefallen mit
weil wir da wirklich genau hingucken ja
ich würde folgen ratschlag geben die die
offensive gehen sich informieren und
nicht die sorgen für sich behalten und
verdruckst sich im hintergrund sondern
sind offensiv informieren dass auch mit
anderen diskutieren und dann für sich
entscheidet
mir persönlich ist ganz wichtig noch
einmal zu betonen dass der
wissenschaftliche konsens der auf daten
und fakten und untersuchungen beruht
eindeutig sagt dass impfungen
ein wirksames um sicheres mittel zur
vorbeugung von krankheiten zur
eindämmung von infektions- und das für
mich ganz wichtig persönlich noch einmal
zu betonen
diese folge hat auf jeden fall noch mal
gezeigt wie unfassbar wichtig ein
offener dialog ist dass ich glaube das
haben wir alle aus dieser folge gelernt
und wie wichtig ist dass wir uns alle zu
hören das haben wir gemacht wenn euch
die folge auch zum nachdenken angeregt
hat euch gut gefallen hat und ihr mehr
davon sehen wollt dann freue ich mich
natürlich sehr wenn ihr diesen county
abonniert das könnt ihr hier machen
eine weitere 13 fragen folge seht ihr
hier oben und ein weiteres video zum
thema findet ihr hier unten